JEREMY WALKER: Hi, I'm Jeremy
Walker, a YouTube Developer
Advocate.
We're continuing our series with
our GDEs or Google Developer
Experts.
Again, these are
people that help us out
with the YouTube APIs.
And we're going to talk a little
bit with Tim Wintle today.
And he came out all
the way from London.
Enjoy the show.
And we're continuing our
conversation with our GDEs,
and we have one of the
veterans out here from London.
Tim, how was the flight?
TIM WINTLE: Fairly long, but OK.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah,
a little jet lag.
I know what you mean.
When I traveled across the pond,
I was little out of it myself.
But you've done great.
So we were talking a little
bit about the Data API, which
for you that don't
know is basically
the API that lets you
do most everything you
do on YouTube but via the API.
I wanted to get your feeling
from the last year of what
was the feature that
launched that you
found the most interesting?
TIM WINTLE: So I think
the one that immediately
had the biggest potential was
the in-video programming where
you can specify particular
thumbnails or particular links
that you want to come
up to other videos
at the end of all
of your videos.
JEREMY WALKER: Ah, yeah,
that's a good feature.
For users that don't know, it
gives a nice little overlay
where you can feature a
video or your channel.
When you were integrating with
it, was there any surprises?
TIM WINTLE: So just how well
that it works across devices
compared to some of
the older annotations
that's been out
for a while where
it took a very
long time for them
to start to work on mobile
and on different platforms.
This just seems to
work very cleanly.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes.
That's true.
So for our users that
don't know, in the UI,
you can create
freeform annotations
where you can put them
wherever you want.
But like you said, those weren't
supported across every device.
So we covered the surprises.
Do you have any feature
requests or anything
you'd like to see
in that API, then?
TIM WINTLE: So I'd love to see
that widen more and enable some
of the other uses for
the freeform annotations.
My favorite one is the select
an interactive video story
where you can select
your next steps
to continue the narrative.
Like those skip to page 130.
JEREMY WALKER: Books.
Yeah, pick your
poison-- I definitely
know what you're talking about.
Well, great.
Thanks for coming out
and for all the support.
We really appreciate it.
And for the audience,
please join us
with the interview with
the rest of our experts.
Thank you.